et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
olivier faur bonjour bonjour si beaucoup
d'être avec nous des passionnés ma
première secrétaire du parti socialiste
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview
en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
fabrice lecerf aux dons bonjour fabrice
jau regard des journaux du groupe ebra
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france on va bien sûr parler de la crise
sanitaire et de l'actualité mais un mot
sur ce que vient dire marc raynaud
d'abord olivier faure sur la réforme des
retraites
elle n'est pas enterrée elle encore sur
la table mais il ne peut pas garantir
qu'elle soit examinée par le parlement
en 2021
est-ce qu'elle verra le jour cette
réforme des retraites d'ici la fin du
quinquennat quelles contorsions pour
dire qu'à très fort mais tout raizen
réforme qui est conspué qui a été
rejetée par les français
et qu'au fond l'aco vide a permis de ne
pas dire c'était un retrait en rase
campagne et donc le maintenant le
gouvernement essaie de nous expliquer
que ça va revenir et c'est pour ne pas
désespérer celles et ceux qui veulent
croire qu'il est un gouvernement qui a
pris les choses à bras le corps mais
vous n'y croyez pas mais non seulement
je n'y crois pas non plus je ferai tout
pour ce ne soit pas le cas parce que
cette réforme c'était d'abord une
réforme injuste
une réforme qui était une réforme qui
était contraire à ce que l'état social
organisé depuis la libération et non que
oui je pense que il n'est pas nécessaire
d'y revenir
fabrice oui autres questions d'actualité
c'est cette enquête de la fondation
jaurès que vous suivez j'imagine et qui
donnent une majorité assez importante de
français 55% qui se disent favorables au
retour de la peine de mort et
simultanément d'ailleurs à la présence
d'un chef fort à la tête du pays
qu'est ce que ça dit de la société
olivier faur ça dit que sur ces
questions là il y à une émotion qui est
née
et au terrorisme liées aux crimes de
sang qui sont malheureusement
régulièrement racontée par rapport à la
presse et ce n'est pas un reproche c'est
une réalité et que donc il y à une
émotion qui naît et qui amène un certain
nombre de françaises et de français a
considéré que la peine de mort peut être
dissuasive et c c'est un combat qu'il
faut à nouveau mené rappeler que ça n'a
jamais dit ce dic qui que ce soit et
c'est pas parce que vous émettez la
peine de mort aujourd'hui que vous aurez
moins de faire quoi chez les frères
kwasi savait qu'ils allaient mourir et
ils sont morts ça nous a pas empêchés
d'être les tueurs de charlie donc ça
n'est pas en répondant à la violence par
la violence
fut-elle légitime que l'on arrive à que
l'on arrête que l'on interrompt les
criminels et on va parler de cette crise
sanitaire pas ou peu de décisions
nationales mais un tour de vis donné
dans certaines régions la gironde les
bouches-du-rhône la guadeloupe est ce
que pour vous c'est la bonne méthode
pardon juste quelle est la méthode ne
donne pas de ne pas prendre de décisions
uniforme sur le territoire national mais
de donner la main aux territoires et
finalement de prendre des mesures
territorialisées c'est ça que vous
appelez de méthode
en tout cas c'est la méthode castex vous
pensez que ça n'en est pas une c'est pas
une méthode
j'avais pas compris la question parce
que je me disais où est la méthode dont
on parle je vois bien que même y compris
sur week-end on a eu un premier ministre
qui a d'abord fait sonner les f1 fait
appel et hambourg et qui a convoqué les
français à 16 eur puis à 17 heures puis
1 et à ce moment là il est venu pour
nous dire rien ou si peu et on nous
expliquant qu' il allait en fait demandé
aux préfets de lui faire des
propositions dans les jours qui suivent
mais là je me suis dit mais
et sort de son lit qu'est-ce qui fait
enfin casque je me trouvais ça brouillon
vous trouvez ça désordonnée la bonne
façon c'était quoi c'était de commencer
en fait part demandé au préfet quelles
étaient leurs préconisations et ensuite
d'en faire le tri et de venir les
annoncer aux françaises et aux français
vous ne pouvez pas laisser s'installer
une forme d' indécision d'imprécisions
d'improvisation qui donne à chacun le
sentiment que l'état n'ait pas tenu et
surtout qui laisse prospérer ensuite
toutes les théories les plus fumeuses
les plus complotistes les fakes news et
c'est parce que ces sentiments devez
vous que l'état n'ait pas tenu
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui j'ai le sentiment qu'il ya
une improvisation permanente qui est
coupable parce qu'elles donnent le
sentiment je ne dis pas que c'est pas
tenu je ne dis pas que il n'y a pas
derrière une volonté mais le courage
c'est aussi d'exprimer les choix que
l'on vende entend faire si on pense que
l'étape suivante c'est par exemple leur
confinement total ou partiel etc
il faut le dire pourquoi parce que ça
permet à chacun de comprendre quelles
sont les menaces qui pèsent sur nous et
donc de faire en sorte que les
françaises et les français intègrent
l'ensemble des dispositifs auxquels il
pourrait être contraint s'ils ne
prennent pas les précautions qui sont
préconisées par tous les ennemis on a
beaucoup reproché pendant la première
vague au gouvernement de ne pas entendre
les élus locaux de ne pas entendre les
territoires là il le fait est ce qu'on
lui reproche pas un peu tout et son
contraire et non il n'entend pas et
territoires il délègue parfois de
manière
enfin c'est pas pr non prendre un autre
exemple l'exemple scolaire si vous ne
fixez pas la règle au plan national et
que chaque directeur d'école est
confronté à la question de savoir ce
qu'il fait d'un enfant qui se mouche et
tous les enfants qui vont à l'école
entre 3 et 8 ans ils passent leur vie à
se moucher être malades parce qu'ils
sont entrain de s'immuniser et donc
qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce que on
considère que c'est un problème qui
serait à l'échelon de chaque école c'est
que train de se passer en réalité et moi
je vois les écoles qui répondent très
différemment à cette question où est ce
que vous dites abandonné il ya une règle
et c'est le critère par exemple je t'ai
pas de la fièvre qui est déterminant
pour refuser un enfant à l'école
autrement vous avez des enfants qui
n'auront plus jamais à l'école donc
c'est ces questions là qui sont posées
et j'aimerais que parfois le
gouvernement prenne ses responsabilités
et quand il prend
citations les territoires ce qu'il doit
faire et bien il les interroge dire
qu'il aurait été assez logique qui le
convoque l'ensemble des présidents de
région l'ensemble des raisons de
département qu'il voit avec eux ce qui
est en fait leur façon à eux de
concevoir le traitement de l'épidémie et
ensuite prendre des décisions ce n'est
pas en fait une espèce de truc au petit
bonheur la chance avec des gens qui font
des choses ça va ça ne va pas ça ne
colle pas il faut renier une france avec
des mesures à la carte
mais je crains surtout que les
françaises et les français ne respectent
plus suffisamment les gestes clairs sur
demande et parce qu'ils ont le sentiment
que quand on regarde le département d'à
côté et parfois est limitrophe et il
suffit de 500 mètres pour changer de
département et vous avez un département
où on vous dit blanc l'autre département
où vont dire on vous dit noir et donc on
a quand même l'impression que vous êtes
partisan d'une méthode plus radicale sur
le sujet je suis partisan d'une méthode
qui soit plus sanitaires et donc il
s'agit pas d'être radical ou pas radical
je souhaite que on est à chaque fois des
lignes qu'ils soient des lignes claires
qui permettent à chacun de savoir à quoi
il est exposé j'étais assez perturbé
parfois par cette idée que même d'un
quartier à l'autre du département à
l'autre d'une région à l'autre les mêmes
mots ne produisent pas les mêmes effets
et donc il ya un moment où si vous
voulez que les règles soient appliquées
il faut qu'elle soit à peu près un peu
uniformiser parce qu'autrement vous ne
savait plus à quel saint nous vouer
il est socialiste qui demande notamment
une communication quotidienne sur cette
crise sanitaire pour vous il ya un
manque de transparence de la part du
gouvernement
il ya une improvisation que je trouve
incompréhensible
après de longs mois de crise sanitaire
ce qui pouvait éventuellement se
justifier au démarrage de la crise
aujourd'hui nous ne l'est plus ça
n'était pas normal que le ministre blanc
kerr john c
enfin la révision du protocole sanitaire
moins d'une semaine avant la rentrée
scolaire avec des détecteurs d'école que
j'ai rencontrés qui ne savait pas du
tout s'il brême recevoir les parents
dans la cour de l'école comme chaque
année ce qui pourrait les emmener dans
les classes enfin c'est pas assez prises
avec une épidémie qui évolue quand même
de deux randonneurs en réalité une
semaine est énorme par rapport à
l'épidémie évolue sur 48 72 heures mais
l'épidémie est les volumes enfin les
causes de l'épidémie on les connaît
maintenant depuis des mois et des mois
on sait qu'elles sont restées barrières
on sait quelles sont les mesures à
prendre même si le gouvernement a
beaucoup hésité lui même en nous
expliquant d'abord qu'il fallait pas de
masque et maintenant il fait des masques
partout bon c'est sûr que ça n'a pas
aidé à la pédagogie et à la bonne
compréhension mais justement si on ne
veut pas donner le sentiment que tout ça
est brouillon improvisé et au fond ne
correspond pas à une réalité
eh bien il faut un peu d'ordre si vous
ne mettez pas d'ordre là dedans les gens
qui ont ce sentiment
les françaises et les français ont le
sentiment qu'au fond on les ballades
mais qu'on ne sait pas très bien où on
va et donc ça affaiblit le dispositif et
le discours de précaution qui est
aujourd'hui tenu et cette crise
sanitaire qui entraîne une crise
économique une crise sociale et le
parlement qui va se prononcer dans les
prochaines semaines sur les mesures du
plan de relance d'un montant de 100
milliards vous êtes assez critique vous
avec ce plan de relance dans le journal
du dimanche dimanche vous vous disiez ce
pognon de dengue ne peut pas servir à
reconstruire en moins bien la france
d'avant est ce que ça veut dire que vous
ne voterez pas ces mesures du plan de
relance
ça veut dire que il y avait vent des
comptes
est-ce que vous avez déjà gagné à
l'euromillion
malheureusement donc non et à l'euro
milliards encore l avantage bon là vous
avez en fait quelqu'un qui vient de
gagner l'euro millions il remis hier
parce qu'en réalité il faudra rembourser
et la question se pose de savoir qu'ils
remboursent soir mais quelqu'un qui est
dispose de 100 milliards d'euros
et pour relancer l'économie c'est une
occasion formidable de dire qu'on va la
relancer mais sur des bases différentes
on aurait pu avoir un gouvernement qui
disent ça qu'il aille jusqu'au bout de
la logique de la transition sociale
écologique numérique et donc fasse en
sorte que cet argent serve à réorienter
l'économie met pas du tout en fait vous
avez là un président qui donne en fait
aux entreprises
la fin des impôts dit de production sans
aucune contrepartie sans aucune
condition
alors qu'il aurait fallu que toutes les
aides qui sont apportées aujourd'hui
soit conditionnée à un plan qui les
emmènera une transition quelle
contrepartie il aurait fallu pour vous
mais par exemple qui des contreparties
sur le plan social sur le plan
écologique est à dire que vous ne pouvez
pas dire une entreprise du secteur
automobile et bien vous allez refaire
comme avant il faut bien je comprends
que ça peut pas se faire du jour au
lendemain mais il aurait fallu dire cet
argent il sert d'abord à faire en sorte
que vous accomplissiez une mutation et
que vous puissiez dans le même temps
former vos salariés à ces mutations pour
qu'il ne soit pas la variable
d'ajustement de cette transition
voilà un élément qui m'aurait pour le
coup séduit vous êtes en train de dire
qu'on loupe une opportunité agents soit
à me dire que c'est une occasion manquée
et une formidable occasion manquée vous
vous rendez compte 100 milliards je le
répète 100 milliards enfin à quel moment
qu'elle quel est le gouvernement qui a
disposé de 100 milliards pourrait
réorienter l'économie
aucun depuis aussi loin que je me
souvienne et donc il y a là une
opportunité qui était une opportunité
majeure
or vous avez là un gouvernement qui fait
semblant qui vous dit je mets 30
milliards bon il ferait faire ses
comptes je suis pas sûr que sur les 30
milliards mais même si vous dites je
mets 30 milliards pour la décarbonation
de l'économie et qui voudraient 70
milliards sur l'économie carbonnel vous
vous dites c'est quoi le truc en fait où
on va c'est qu'elle elle quel est le
sens profond de ce qui est proposé
en réalité il fait exactement ce qui
leur est fait avant la coved et à dire
qu'il voulait baisser les impôts des
entreprises
ilves et impôts des entreprises la polo
que les entreprises et donc voilà il
fait le fait sans conditions enfin c'est
la suite malheureusement logique de tout
ce qu'il a déjà entrepris avant la crise
sanitaire
or il nous avait dit je vais me
réinventer mais où voyez-vous de la
réinvention
il n'y a aucune raison de sa part il est
dans la droite ligne de ce que les
libéraux ont toujours fait et même je
regarde ce que font nos voisins
allemands qui sont pas forcément des
gauchistes qui sont même plutôt des
conservateurs avec madame merkel
eh bien ils ont eu un volet dans leurs
plans de relance d'abord qui est un
volet design brison un plan de relance
qui est plus conséquent que le nôtre qui
représente plus de la part de la caisse
nationale que ce que nous avons nous
consacrer
à la caisse nationale à la au plan de
relance pardon et eux ils ont par
exemple me dit mais il faut que la tva
sur les produits de 1ère nécessité
baisse pour que les personnes les plus
fragiles la société allemande puissent
retrouver en fait un niveau de confort
et de vie après cette crise sanitaire et
donc permettre de relancer la
consommation
mais en france vous avez vu où les
mesures pour les plus faibles pour les
plus pauvres ne sert à rien on aurait pu
avoir des mesures sur les apl on aurait
pu avoir un fonds qui soit créée pour
impayés de loyer on aurait pu avoir
simplement le rsa ouvert aux moins de 26
ans parce qu'on voit bien que ce sont
les étudiants et pas que les étudiants
et tous ceux qui aujourd'hui n'ont plus
accès aux petits boulots et c1 qu'ils
sont en train de de garnir les files
d'attentes des assauts du coeur et de
toutes celles et ceux qui organisent des
distributions alimentaires
donc il ya oui il ya un problème on a
l'impression que les allemands font tout
mieux que nous y compris quand on écoute
le chef de file des socialistes mais ils
font pas tout mieux que nous mais là en
l'occurrence je trouve qu'il ya des
moments où qu'ils se posent les
questions mieux que nous les y répondent
mieux que nous et j'y peux rien c'est
comme ça d'abord peut-être sont ils
influencés par kaiku de thil davantage
les minoritaires chez eux que sont les
grünen les verts et le spd socialistes
allemands ont peut être est ce cela la
raison j'en sais rien mais en fait ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est moi
j'aurais tellement aimé que prendre
prendre le chef de l'état aux mots nous
avait dit je ferai en sorte que quoi
qu'il en coûte etc
mais on voit bien que rien rien n'a
suivi il aurait fallu que par exemple
sur la crise sanitaire
on est aujourd'hui les éléments qui ont
elles de dire que oui on est très
heureux que le re localiser oui on est
en train de de répondre aux besoins des
premiers de corvée ou tranchées qu'on
est en train de revaloriser vraiment
leur métier tout ça vous avez vu ou
nulle part mais c'est reserrement
olivier faur parce que du coup mais a
répondu quelle sera la position des
parlementaires socialistes mais moi je
suis contre ce plan dont vous ferez
contre on va discuter de ça en groupe
sur la façon dont on s'abstient aussi on
vote contre
parce que on peut pas dire qu on est en
plus contre tous donc mais enfin le
signal que donner aujourd'hui est un
mauvais signal et donc moi je ne voterai
pas ce plan de relance donc chantre
l'abstention ou
le vote contre un mot sur le projet de
loi qui va arriver plus tard à l'automne
le projet de loi de lutte contre les
séparatismes et marlène schiappa qui a
annoncé un cycle de concertation
notamment avec les élus et les
parlementaires est ce que vous savez
déjà si vous allez être reçus ou pas
encore donc une idée toujours pas quelle
est votre position quelle est la
position du parti socialiste sur le
projet de loi de lutte contre les
séparatistes qu'est-ce qui doit y avoir
dedans pour vous j'avais presque vous
posez la même question c'est quoi le
séparatisme prouvons moi je ne sais pas
en fait c'est y apprennent des
définitions d'abord en fait j'ai
l'impression que là on est en train de
nous ouvrir un grand débat sur
l'identité nationale qui va prolonger
plonger ce pays dans des abîmes de
perplexité où on va opposer les uns aux
autres sans qu'il y ait de réelles
réponses parce que la réponse la seule
réponse pour moi c'est la république et
à ce qu'il ya besoin aujourd'hui d'une
loi sur le séparatisme quel est le
problème en fait et quels sont les trous
dans la raquette qu'est ce qui manque
aujourd'hui à la république pour se
battre contre ceux qui justement en sont
les ennemis moi je ne sais pas je crois
que la loi elle existe à tous niveaux
je ne vois pas quels sont les gadgets
qu'on veut inventer j'ai entendu dire
qu'il fallait arrêter de financer les
ennemis de la république mais on peut
déjà le faire en fait un tournoi pro
c'est l'application qui pose problème
aujourd'hui c'est pas l'application sait
y compris
qu'est ce que c'est que cet objet
politique qu'on veut mettre dans le dans
les mains des français qu'elle est le
débat qu'on veut organiser si c'est pour
que ce soit un exutoire nationale où
chacun dénonce son voisin je suis contre
moi je prenons un exemple simple on a eu
une polémique s'est aussi avec une
journaliste qui a
11 septembre mis sur twitter en fait la
vidéo d'une jeune étudiante qui pourra
poser ses recettes de cuisine et qui
avait un foulard qui est donc témoigner
de son appartenance à la religion
musulmane et elle met son pour seul
commentaire 11 septembre 2001 les 100
points c'est que il ya un lien entre les
terroristes du rôle trade center et
cette jeune femme qui proposait ses
fiches cuisine
mais est-ce que c'est l'âge et la forêt
et non c'est l'un des jeux films
d'incidents et si si on considère qu'il
ya une incitation à la haine raciale ou
une incitation à la haine tout court
et bien la loi permet d'aller devant la
justice
cette jeune journaliste qui derrière a
fait l'objet de condamnations sur
twitter de menaces de mort bien là aussi
les menaces de mort et aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on année par la loi et vous pouvez
condamner quelqu'un pour cette seule
raison quelle est votre position sur des
affaires du coup qu'est ce que c'est
vous condamner le tweet de judith
waintraub dont la légèreté
je condamne enfin je ne suis d'accord
avec personne je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ce qu'elle dit en laissant penser
que toutes les femmes qui portent
aujourd'hui le foulard sont des
terroristes en puissance et je suis
contre celles et ceux qui parce qu'elle
a commis cette bévue
enfin même que cette bévue a fait cette
faute est bien sont là à la condamner à
mort bien sûr que ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas tolérable ce qu'elle dit mais ce
n'est pas tolérable n'ont plus
aujourd'hui de laisser penser que pour
une expression plus que malheureuses et
bien on a le droit de un amor qui que ce
soit et pour vous aucun problème avec
cette jeune femme qui se présente à la
télé avec un voile islamique
d'abord pourquoi islamique en fait il ya
un foulard je crois qu'à sa longue de
d'endroits dans le fin d'un autre pays
où des femmes portent le foulard et il
n'est pas considéré comme une menace à
qui que ce soit enfin ou alors il faut
que la scène d'un seul coup on dise que
désormais plus personne ne peut porter
le foulard c'est qu'il n'est ce qui
n'est pas pour l'instant
barrette de qui que ce soit allez on va
passer à un autre sujet d'actualité
c'est la 5g avant tout faire région va
entendre emmanuel macron il s'est
exprimé il
il a défendu le déploiement de la cinq
géants l'écoutent oui nous expliquer
qu'il faut c'est en revenant au modèle
voilà je ne crois pas au modèle amis dit
il à propos de la singer quelle est
votre réaction
est ce que vous croyez le modèle amish
je ne crois pas davantage aux modèles
amis je vais je ne crois pas non plus
qu'on n'ait pas le droit enfin je ne
crois pas qu'on ait aujourd'hui
l'obligation de chercher à moquer celles
et ceux qui posent des questions parce
que le progrès n'est pas toujours un
progrès enfin en tout cas le progrès
technologique n'est pas toujours un
progrès pour l'homme
je suis sûr que emmanuel macron au
moment de l'amiante serait venu
expliquer à tout le monde
actuellement 2 c'était formidable banon
l'amiante n'était pas formidable est-ce
que la 5g et l'amiante mais je ne fais
pas la comparaison entre la 5g vraiment
merci de me reprendre ça permet de
préciser ma pensée je dis simplement que
le progrès doit être aussi interroger et
je n'ai pas je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
aujourd'hui dire que ceux qui condamnent
pas que ceux qui veulent un moratoire
d'abord ai dit que c'était
définitivement non ils disent
interrogeons-nous d'abord et ensuite
prenons la décision je vois que même
bruit bien aujourd'hui propose de
repousser le moment où on attribuera les
fréquences 5g parce que lui-même
considère que ce n'est pas la bonne le
bon moment pour le faire
donc ça veut dire quelque chose ça veut
dire que oui il ya des questions à se
poser et je vois y compris des gens qui
m'écrivent je n'étais pas spécialiste de
la 5g pour tout vous dire mais je vois y
compris des gens aujourd'hui de météo
france qui m'écrivent et qui me disent
savez vous que si on déploie aujourd'hui
à 5 g dans les conditions dans
lesquelles il est prévu qu'elle se
déploie et bien ça va brouiller une
partie des capteurs de météo france et
que les prévisions météorologiques
seront dégradés de l'ordre de 30% ou 40%
bon je découvre ça je découvre que y
compris la puissance de la 5g va être un
problème y compris en termes de
consommation d'énergie à un moment où on
se pose des questions contraire de
réduire
je vois aussi que sur la 5g on
un problème qui est lié à ce qu'on va
faire des objets connectés est ce que
tous les citoyens vont être désormais
tracée dans leur vie quotidienne
par le biais de la 5g ce sont des
questions importantes qu'on ne peut pas
laisser passer parce que un montant
pouvant apparaître sur tes goûts pendant
son commandant se bat comme on en sort
on se pose des questions on a un vrai
débat et à l'issue de ce vrai débat eh
bien on fait des choix mais il ya
beaucoup de choses sur lesquelles il
faut interroger désormais on dire parler
du progrès à l'instant mais par exemple
moi je considère que le télétravail peut
être un progrès mais peut être aussi une
formidable régression donc là aussi ça
suppose que notamment pour la gauche
voilà un chantier gigantesque dans
lequel il faut rentrer justement olivier
faure il nous reste peu de temps je suis
désolé vous avez annoncé être candidat à
votre succession le prochain congrès du
parti socialiste se tiendra donc
mi-décembre vous proposer un printemps
de la gauche et de l'écologie avec
celles et ceux qui le voudront vous dit
qu'il veut aujourd'hui j'espère enfin
talent et on faisait une allusion étude
de la fondation jean jaurès
je crois que ce que fait apparaître
cette étude clairement c'est qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une aspiration pour un bloc
social et écologique
j'ajouterai même démocratique et
féministe qui permettrait à ce pays de
trouver l'occasion d'en finir avec une
aile macro et marine le pen
ce duo mortifère qu'on convoi se
prolonger à l'infini et bien c'est
possible de faire différemment et donc
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que toutes
celles et ceux qui veulent en finir et
bien fasse le choix de l'unité du
rassemblement et fasse le show tout
simplement de la raison parce que vous -
à tout le monde le sait s'il n'y a pas
de rassemblement il y aura ce duel alors
clairement avec qui vous discuté
aujourd'hui pour être clair ce que vous
discutez avec jean luc mélenchon chose
que vous discutez avec yannick jadot
vous discutez avec fabien roussel avec
qui vous discuté mais je discute pour
l'instant avec notamment
mes partenaires écologistes discute avec
les communistes discuter avec génération
est depuis quelques jours je vois que
non pas jean-luc mélenchon mais avec un
4 nages cherche à ouvrir la porte à une
discussion et donc moi je suis ouvert
voilà je suis je cherche à comprendre
qui veut coin et ensuite je souhaite que
vous le comprenez qui veut quoi pas
toujours
je m'interroge souvent mais remarqué une
chose c'est que depuis deux ans et demi
que je suis premier secrétaire je fais
preuve d'une cohérence à toute épreuve
là où je vois beaucoup de gens qui d'une
élection à l'autre change de pied et
change de cap change d'avis moi je
continue et je file tout droit et tout
droit sert à la présidentielle vers
l'idée qu' on a la possibilité
tous rassemblés de mettre fin à ce
quinquennat qui était un canard à bien
des égards des raisons la présidentielle
et régionales vous dites que pour vous
l'union doit commencer dès ces
régionales sauf que les écologistes
disent ben nous on présentera 13
candidats dans les 13 régions
métropolitaines y aura des candidats
estampillés écologie ça part mal quand
même cette union c'est parce qu'ils
disent ils disent qu'il y aura des chefs
de file dans toutes les régions
ensuite est-ce qu'on est suffisamment
intelligent pour se poser la question de
savoir quand on a un chef de file
socialiste sa chef de file communiste un
chef de file l'écologie c'est c'est eh
bien quel est le meilleur ou la
meilleure qui peut nous représenter dans
cette élection et faire en sorte que ce
soit ce candidat cette candidate qui
permettent d'aller à la victoire
moi c'est ce que je souhaite bon
maintenant je ne suis pas là pour courir
après qui que ce soit donc c'est pour ça
que je dis qu'on engageait nous mêmes un
printemps de la gauche et de l'écologie
et viendront celles et ceux qui veulent
dire que c'est pas seulement les partis
politiques ce n'est pas une exclusivité
nous n'avons pas tout inventé nous
n'avons pas la science infuse et donc
moi je souhaite que société civile dit
organe a organisé ce qu'était civique et
bien puisse nous rejoindre des
personnalités des citoyens qui ont
simplement envie de faire vivre justesse
que vous travaillez déjà concrètement à
ces listes à des listes communes pour
les régionales ça arrive vite un les
régionales est ce que vous travaillez
déjà avec les écologistes avec la france
est soumise avec les communistes à des
listes communes de gauche dans les 13
régions on discute bien sûr mais ce que
je demande et moi même aux socialistes
ce week-end je leur ai dit y compris
quand vous composez maintenant
nos listes dire les gens qui va faire le
candidat eh bien on fait pas on prévoit
pas 100 % des candidats ont fait en
sorte de laisser de la place à toutes
celles et ceux qui pourraient venir avec
nous renforcer ce bloc social et
écologique c'est ce qui s'est passé à
marseille des listes y compris pour les
têtes de liste et donc à marseille quand
l'art l'élection municipale
il ya eu la naissance de ce printemps
marseillais eh bien nous sommes les
seuls à avoir accepté dès le départ
cette démarche qui a été la démarche
victorieuse personne n'était là et au
premier tout il n'y avait ni les
insoumis ni les écologistes il y avait
les communistes avec nous et donc on a
gagné parce que nous avons su nous
ouvrir à d'autres et montrer qu' il y
avait en fait une possibilité de
rassemblement et profondément ce
qu'espèrent les gens qui aujourd'hui ont
le coeur à gauche
et bien tout simplement qu'on a qu'on en
finisse avec les querelles d'ego qui
sont rêvez vous avez allemand sur la
fille ciel et qui sont vous avez cette
volonté est de remettre la gauche
plurielle ans de bataille
l'inventeur de la gaufrette je n'existe
pas s'est exprimé il ya quelques jours
françois hollande
peu après le retour de ces figurants peu
historique comme temporaire du
socialisme c'est un frein pour vous
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais j'ai
accueilli avec à la fois beaucoup
d'égards et beaucoup d'affection
le livre de lionel jospin sur
l'interview dans l'observateur qui était
de l'interview qui remettait à bien des
égards les pendules à l'heure et il a
été je pense assez clair sur y compris
sa volonté de ne pas s'imposer à nouveau
dans le débat politique national
il est un sage désormais qui sait
falloir son point de vue très utile et
n'apparaît crois pas qu'il ait annoncé
son retour dans la vie politique
pour françois hollande rapidement allez
vous êtes déjà exprimé à ce sujet pour
françois hollande je crois que il est
aussi pour être aussi un sage et la part
de son expérience ce serait certainement
une très bonne chose
et merci beaucoup merci olivier faur
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin